im moment warten hier die abgeordneten
auch auf eine namentliche abstimmungen
damit kommen wir noch einmal zu der
generaldebatte von gestern denn diese
namentliche abstimmung die das gleiche
geben wird das ist ein parlamentarisches
nachspiel zur generaldebatte gestern am
mittwoch es ist ja ein höhepunkt oh
gewöhnlicherweise opposition und
regierung in einem regnerischen
schlagabtausch gehen was gestern geschah
sofern sie es nicht verfolgen konnten
die debatte eröffnete gestern als größte
oppositionsfraktion die af.de konkret
deren fraktionsvorsitzender alice weide
und sie kritisierte in ihrer rede unter
anderem die einwanderungspolitik der
bundesregierungen sagte unter anderem
einen satz der nach ansicht von
bundestagspräsident wolfgang schäuble
die grenze dessen überschritten was im
deutschen bundestag gesagt werden sollte
daher gab es einen ordnungsruf des
präsidenten gegen diesen ordnungsruf hat
alice weil heute einspruch eingelegt das
sieht die geschäftsordnung des
bundestages so vor und demnach muss der
deutsche bundestag sich damit befassen
wir wollen ihnen aber erst noch mal den
recht kurzen ausschnitt aus der rede von
gestern von alice weidl zeigen und
entsprechend auch den ordnungsruf des
bundestags präsidentin
da stimmt dagegen burkas kopftuchmädchen
und alimentierte messer männer und
sonstige taugenichts werden unseren
wohlstand
doch wachstum und vor allem den
sozialstaat nicht sicher frau kollegin
weise sie haben in ihrer rede die
formulierung unter anderem
kopftuchmädchen und sonstige taugenichts
sie gebraucht damit diskriminieren sie
alle frauen die ein kopftuch tragen
dafür so wie sie zur ordnung der eu
kommission über die an das war also
gestern der ordnungsruf des bundestags
präsidentin alles weiter hat schriftlich
einspruch eingelegt ich kann ihnen das
einmal vorlesen
ich zitiere es lag kein die würde und
ordnung ins parlament verletzendes
verhalten vor
so in dem brief von alice weiter an den
bundestagspräsidenten das betreffende
zitat lautete dann kommt das zitat was
sie gerade gesehen haben klar
ersichtlich sein schreibt alles weide
dass ich die bezeichnung taugenichts das
sprachlich eindeutig und unzweifelhaft
auf alimentierte messer männer bezog sie
bezog sich damit denkt logisch nicht auf
die burka und auch nicht auf die
kopftuchmädchen daraus ist zu
schlussfolgern dass der ordnungsruf der
aufhebung unterliegt darüber hat die afg
namentliche abstimmung beantragt der
geschäftsordnung ohne aussprache zu
entscheiden
wir kommen zur abstimmung
zur geschäftsordnung
mit von seiten der afg einen
geschäftsordnungsantrag ja herr
präsident die afg fraktion möchte gerne
dass die kollegen der anderen fraktionen
auch genau zur kenntnis nehmen worum es
hier geht und bittet darum und bittet
darum bittet darum den einspruch
vorzulesen
der einspruch ist verteilt worden die
kollegin haben davon kenntnis genommen
die fdp-fraktion verlangt ein die
namentliche abstimmung
ich bitte die schriftführer und
schriftführer die vorgesehenen plätze
einzunehmen
also das war einer der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der fdp fraktion jürgen
braun aber der bundestags- vizepräsident
hans peter friedrich hat es gesagt
genauso wie mir dieser schriftlicher
einspruch von alice weibel vorliegt
liegt der natürlich auch den
abgeordneten vor und dem bundestag
da ein solcher einspruch gegen einen
ordnungsruf gewöhnlicherweise ohne
aussprache vom deutschen bundestag
behandelt wird und auch normalerweise in
einfacher abstimmung hat die afg aber
sie sehen es die abgeordneten stehen im
plenarsaal hierzu namentliche abstimmung
verlangt namentlich abgestimmt kann man
dann also nachlesen
wie jeder und jede einzelne abgeordnete
sich zu diesem thema verhalten hat der
bundestags vizepräsident hans peter
friedrich der erläutert noch einmal wie
jetzt wer abstimmen kann
zustimmung oder ablehnung dieses antrags
der afg sie sehen hier die abgeordneten
stehen an den urnen das ist das übliche
verfahren bei namentlichen abstimmungen
und die roten abstimmungskarten
signalisieren das nein der abgeordneten
und außer der fdp fraktion habe ich hier
im saal noch niemanden mit einer blauen
karte entsprechend für jahr hier gesehen
der bundestag hat ja 709 abgeordnete 92
davon gehören der fdp-fraktion an zwei
fraktionslose abgeordnete gibt es ja
hier im deutschen parlament das sind die
ehemalige parteivorsitzende der afg
frauke petry sie ist ja nicht in die
bundestagsfraktion der afg eingetreten
als diese sich hier konstituierte nach
der wahl und ein weiterer abgeordneter
mario mir hoch von der für die afg
eigentlich in den bundestag gewählt
sitzt hier auch als fraktionsloser
abgeordneter dh alle anderen fraktionen
hätten zusammen 615 stimmen plus die
zwei fraktionslosen plus eben
entsprechend 92 der fdp-fraktion und das
wird hier ein sehr deutliches ergebnis
also interessant ist die abstimmung
nicht aber dieses parlamentarisches
nachspiel dieses ordnungsrufe das gibt
es eben auch nicht so oft und das gehört
eben auch zum parlamentarischen
verfahren dazu die geschäftsordnung des
bundestages die sie das vor in paragraf
39 der geschäftsordnung des bundestages
ist festgeschrieben einspruch gegen den
ordnungsruf oder ausschluss das gibt es
beispielsweise ja auch an präsident kann
auch einen oder eine abgeordnete von der
sitzung ausschließen
also dieser einspruch gegen eine
ordnungsruf da heißt es in paragraph 39
der geschäftsordnung des bundestages
gegen den ordnungsruf kann der
betroffene oder die betroffene in dem
fall bis zum nächsten plenarsitzung tag
schriftlich begründeten einspruch
einlegen
der einspruch ist auf die tagesordnung
dieser sitzung zu setzen
der bundestag entscheidet ohne
aussprache der einspruch hat keine
aufschiebende wirkung also diese
entscheidung sehen sie gleich aber das
wird hier wenn ich hier eben den
plenarsaal schauer an den urnen die
meisten abgeordneten haben entsprechend
ihr abstimmungsverhalten kundgetan und
die abstimmungskarten eingeworfen also
gehe ich davon aus dass das hier sehr
schnell wieder in die reguläre
tagesordnung übergehen wird diese
namentliche abstimmung das ist üblich
egal zu welchem gegenstand abgestimmt
wird die wird dann im hintergrund
ausgezählt und das ergebnis wird dann
ungefähr 15 minuten später verkündet
deswegen sehen sie hier noch einige
bilder schön eingefangen von unsere
unserer regie von dem einen oder anderen
ministern hier von der
fraktionsvorsitzenden der spd andrea
nahles zusammen mit martin schulz im
gespräch und der plenarsaal insgesamt
wird sich jetzt aber etwas lehren und
vor allem die fachpolitiker für
wirtschaft und energie und natürlich die
haushälter die in einer solchen woche
immer ganz besonders gefordert sind an
diesen vier sehr langen sitzungstagen
die werden dann hier im plenarsaal vor
allem platz nehmen denn als nächstes
wird entsprechend der einzelplan für
wirtschaft und energie aufgerufen
bundestags vizepräsident hans peter
friedrich hat jetzt gefragt ob noch ein
abgeordneter hier im saal ist er seine
stimme noch nicht abgegeben hat das ist
nicht der fall
deswegen ist diese abstimmung jetzt
entsprechend geschlossen es wird wie
gesagt im hintergrund ausgezählt jetzt
gibt es das ergebnis der namentlichen
abstimmungen gegenüber dem einspruch von
alles weil es gegen eine in der letzten
sitzung hat ein ordnungsruf wurden
insgesamt 636 stimmen abgegeben mit jahr
hat für den anspruch haben gestimmt 85
kollegen mit nein haben gestimmt
549 enthaltungen zwei der einspruch ist
damit abgelehnt
das war das zu erwartende ergebnisse in
der tat so da ging es darum dass der
bundestag darüber abstimmen musste
namentlich das alles weil gegen den
ordnungsruf des bundestagspräsidenten
wolfgang schäuble einspruch eingelegt
hatte und es gab für diesen einspruch 85
jahre stimmen die afg hat 92
fraktionsmitglieder also kann man davon
ausgehen aber es ist auch nachzulesen
denn es wurde ja namentlich abgestimmt
dass nur auf die abgeordnete für diesen
anspruch gestimmt haben